bei mir im studio ist jetzt der
kriminalist professor christian matzdorf
hermannsdorf wir haben es gerade auch
immer von unserem bild chefreporter
frank schneider gehört also mindestens
500 terabyte daten wurden sichergestellt
ich glaube das ist einfach eine
unvorstellbare größe können sie uns
helfen dass ein bisschen einzuordnen wie
groß sind fünf terabyte kann man das
irgendwie vergleichen
der ganze fall ist fast unvorstellbar
auch für kriminalisten die datenmengen
die anfallen sind für kommunale
techniker eine herausforderung wie sie
fast noch nie dagewesen ist zum
vergleich 27 terabyte bei den panama
papers hier haben wir es mit 500 600 800
der mengen daten der arbeit zu tun einen
terabyte 2000 stunden filme
beispielsweise wenn sie das hochrechnen
dann kommen in dimensionen die fast
nicht fassbar sind die ermittler auf der
pressekonferenz auch gesagt dass sie
jetzt mit hochdruck daran arbeiten
wollen dass auszuwerten wie lange
brauchen ermittler dann für diese
datenmenge wenn sie sagen dass ein
terabyte schon 20 20 heute 2000 stunden
filme sind das sehr unvorstellbar als
mit den herkömmlichen mitteln des
dichtens das einfache visuell erarbeiten
das wird man nicht weiter kommen wir
werden wahrscheinlich dann in diesem
fall künstliche intelligenz einsetzen
müssen
diese intelligenz muss auch angelernt
werden also auch gefüttert werden mit
material aus diesem fund und das ist
eine aufgabe die alleine schon eine ganz
große herausforderung ist und wie kann
es sein dass die daten so verschlüsselt
in das wurde auch auf der
pressekonferenz bekannt gegeben dass die
wirklich professionell verschlüsselt
sind das bis jetzt noch nicht alles
lesbar ist wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
die täter schützen sich natürlich auch
vor der strafverfolgung und gute dateien
verschlüsselungssysteme können die
polizei technik vor ganz große aufgaben
stellen das kann also schon ein problem
seien alle daten tatsächlich verfügbar
zu machen und dann kommt ja die
aussetzungsfrist danach also allein der
erste teil wird wahrscheinlich einen
großen zeitraum in anspruch nehmen auf
der pressekonferenz sagte auch der
polizeipräsident von münster rainer
furth das selbst erfahrenste beamte an
die grenzen des menschlich erträglichen
gestoßen sind
das kann man sich bei den schilderungen
die wir gerade gehört haben ja nur zu
gut vorstellen aber sie kommen ja aus
dem gebiet sie waren auch selber
ermittler
wie bekommt man diese bilder wieder auf
im kopf sie merken ja schon dass ich
auch eine belegte stimme habe mir fällt
es schwer hier professionelle distanz zu
wahren
wir geben die dinge eben auch vor dem
hintergrund der dinge die ich selber
erlebt habe der bilder die ich im kopf
habe und wenn sie mich so direkt fragen
man kriegt diese bilder gar nicht mehr
aus dem kopf wird immer nennen
psychologen betreut dann oder das ist
heute glücklicherweise ein standard und
dringend auch sicherlich dringend
notwendig gleichwohl kann man diese
bilder nicht ausradieren man muss
möglichkeiten finden kompensations
neutralisation techniken und mit diesen
bildern umgehen zu können und all das
was anders situationen damit ausgelöst
wird und wie arbeiten die polizisten
jetzt genau also die reihenfolge also da
muss man so die kriminalistische arbeit
die es schon sehr weit fortgeschritten
das haben wir mit diesen misserfolg hier
schon dass an diesem mittel mit erfolg
gesehen wir sind jetzt im bereich der
kriminaltechnik und wir müssen sehen
dass die kommunaltechnik sich so schnell
aufstellt dass die daten einmal
tatsächlich verfügbar gemacht werden
und daneben eine ganz schnelle möglichst
mehrgleisige auswertungsmethode gefunden
wird am ende steht leider aber immer
wieder die manuelle sichtung und dann
noch und da kommt niemand drum herum
jetzt haben wir auch gehört dass der
täter der haupttäter erst 27 jahre alt
ist er soll davor auch schon auffällig
gewesen sein schon vorbestraft gewesen
sein wegen des besitzes von
kinderpornografie
ich glaube ich hatte etwas im kopf von
17 jahren schon ist eine neue generation
der täter das wird immer jünger werden
das thema kinderpornografie pädophilie
ist ein team das von alters chrome
ubiquitär es da gibt es keine gruppen
die besonders stark belastet sind und
insofern ist das keine überraschung
sie haben wir auch das spektrum der
täter hier die dafür bekommen haben oder
täterinnen gesehen was das alter angeht
das alles mit dabei von 27 hoch bis in
die sechziger dann vielen dank für den
er versucht bei uns im studio heimatdorf
man merkt das ist ja auch nicht ich weiß
tatsächlich nicht sehr leicht darüber zu
reden